right now rental home costs are rising
all across the valley chances are you
know someone who's rent jumped in some
cases more than 20 percent maybe it's
happened to you orco man alive tonight
with what is causing the increase and
why you should dig out your lease
agreement orco
well brian renting a home like this one
here in las vegas used to be much
cheaper than it is now and experts say
thanks to more demand and covet era
policies many renters feel locked out of
this option
it's scary it's really scary times mia
browning is worried she lives in this
rental home in summerlin and says costs
are getting crazy i was shocked i
couldn't believe the
difference in price i used to pay 1300
for 2 000 square foot home rental now
i'm paying 2 200. now between utilities
and groceries everything is you know on
a budget according to core logic the las
vegas metro area had the second highest
year-over-year increase in single-family
rent prices in the country this june at
12.9 percent real estate expert andrew
levitt says there are a couple reasons
we had a huge rush from a lot of the
surrounding states it's not just
california it's oregon it's washington
that also came down here more demand
means a jump in price levitt also says
eviction moratoriums during kovid are
playing a role the rental costs had to
go up to cover those costs some people
tell us landlords have even increased
rent during a lease but levitt says
that's allowed if it's in your agreement
in fact clark county and the state of
nevada have no limits on how high rent
can be raised you signed off on that
there's not really a law that's going to
stop anyone from doing that to avoid all
this levitt's advice is to buy if you
can mortgage you have a 30-year
agreement payment's not going to change
that's something browning plans to do i
am hoping to buy as soon as possible
hundreds of you have commented on our
facebook page about the rising rental
costs and for those of you looking at
your lease agreement if your landlord
asks you to pay more rent and that is
not in your agreement you should seek
legal help one of those options is the
legal aid center of southern nevada
that's number right on your screen
reporting live tonight orco mana 8 news
now